[Music]
big shout out to the new york knicks
it's playoff time baby right now i'm
about to salute some of the great
players from the knicks
from the past and the present restoring
and feeling in the city
let's go next pay close attention
[Music]
julius randu respect he deserve it last
julius we seen this good with julius
serving
barry been on his toes give him his
flowers while he's alive
somebody bring derek a rose carmelo
anthony that boy had a gift
and jail used to be shooting like he had
a smith
allen ain't from houston but he shot
like a rocket when anthony brought his
mason the competition got blinded
bernard was a king
so was larry johnson john starks dunked
on jordan in the garden
willis read the defense repeatedly hat
trick you ain't back you down in the
post that was patrick i say frasier
i ain't talking joe the boxer walt
frazier the legendary [ __ ] vodka earl
of pearl monroe
his game was timeless stephan marbury
was coney island's finest amari was a
star they admired
mark jackson and oakley was on fire then
quickly against freeware or get choked
quick i got three words for you
let's go next salute william wesley what
are you doing i like it
steven a smith predicted that he's a
psychic we here
now new york never quit i got three
words for you
let's go next let's go
next let's go next
let's go next
[Music]
basketball